10 stipule et dans cette convention que
lors de faits la cne civilité l'arbite
pourra déposer plainte
auprès de la gendarmerie quelques soit
la gendarmerie dans les 24 heures la
gendarmerie pouvoir une enquête de
flagrance
à ce titre le coq lui aura donné des
instructions aux services de gendarmerie
de police ou accélérer les enquêtes
une fois l'enquêté terminée le parquet
pourra se saisir
il fait en sorte que les procédures
judiciaires soient accélérées
c'est un signal fort pour dire qu'au
fait larbitre aujourd'hui est il
considéré à une mission comme celle de
gendarmes du pompier et qu'il faut
renforcer sa protection